hello and welcome to my video series of
mall bioexplain in three minutes where i
explain the concept of molecular biology
in less than three minutes or so
so if you are new in this channel hit
that subscribe button
in this installment we'll talk about
gradient pcr which is a technique that
allows an
empirical determination of an optimal
primer annealing temperature
so the goal of gradient pcr is to
determine the optimal
primer and needing temperature which
would give a specific amplification
and good yield so a range of temperature
is used in the primer annealing step
instead of one particular temperature so
if you look if you have a top view of
the thermal cycler plate
this is how the temperature varies and
i'll tell you
that how exactly this is done
so let's talk about how we set up the
gradient pcr
in order to set up the gradient pcr we
just have to use the normal pcr mix
the template dna the forward and reverse
primer dntp
tag polymerase and the buffer so
everything is
as simple as that and just like a normal
pcr
but the difference lies in the pcr
program
and the way the thermal cycler is the
cycler is programmed in terms of
temperature
so for this example the cycler
would have a temperature range from 50
degree centigrade
to 65 degree centigrade with the
increment
of 2.5 degree centigrade right and this
is how
the thermal cycler would heat up
in this particular step so instead of
one allelic temperature we are using
multiple different aniline temperature
just to test at which particular
temperature primary annealing is optimum
and we get a
proper amplification which is specific
so a linear gradient is established
with the help of a peltier block which
is inside the pcr machine
and once you are done with the pcr and
run your
product in the agarose chill you get
the amplification as a function of
temperature and in this particular
example you can see at 62.3 degrees
celsius temperature
the amplification is more or less
specific and with
a very low primer timer so this
particular temperature would be an
optimal temperature
for conducting this kind of pcr reaction
so overall gradient pcr is a
standardization
protocol for any kind of pcr
it is advisable that before you perform
any
pcr you can perform a gradient pcr to
understand the efficiency of the
reaction and
with and whether the amplicon is
specific or not
so with that i'll say goodbye to you
guys if you like this video
give it a big thumbs up don't forget to
like share and subscribe thank you